Good godly moodley did remove me.
I'm sure someone must must've Joey.
People steal everything.
Yeah.
This is
fucking unbelievable.
Joey's in the far right.
That's insane that we were so cute at the sexy lucky seven.
Can you get it?
So just his whole body fills.
His mom was 44 I was 44 there was an uncle.
Lucky seven.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Look at you dude.
So how old are you in this picture?
1414 God damn Joe.
You cute.
You're cute as a button.
Look at David Ruiz turning around and talking to the microphone so people can
hear this too.
That kid right there really tough on this screen to that kid with the Afro was a
very interesting story.
This guy right here,
because we were,
we were horrible basketball team at Mckinley.
Can you go full screen?
Moved in our neighborhood.
He could jump.
He was five foot eight but this kid could fucking jump like Julius Erving.
So he was Dominican.
His name was Louis Hernandez.
I'm from Jersey.
Just playing that.
They just cut it short and called him Louie the Nigga.
They said,
fuck it.
We don't care if he's Dominican.
We're not going to even think about that.
We're just gonna.
This is David [inaudible] as they called him that to his face too,
like Louise and Megan.
When did he get pissed?
Fuck you bitch.
And he was a tough kid.
He got manager.
When you come to terms like I think he bit slap two or three people he did was
we used to do acid when we first started smoking weed in the eighth grade,
we go behind the soccer field and north Bergen and he let us blow smoke into his
afro and see the smoke come out of the [inaudible].
How cool is
this was the crew,
so I knew motherfuckers scroll down to the,
all right,
this kid,
he not,
that kid dad was David Black.
We graduated together and I knew him after the fact that one night he came into
Joe married,
it's like dog,
you gotta call you gotta give me a ride.
If he give me a ride,
I'll give you a rock.
All right.
We gave him a ride.
He gets out of the corner of Western Yoga.
My three minutes later,
he comes running back bleeding with his head pulled.
I go,
what happened was I went in to rob my sister.
I mean he was serious.
He had coke rocks,
but everybody,
a chunk of his fucking hat,
she caught him on the way out as he was pulling out of the window and she just
took,
he was bleeding.
He robbed
three in the morning.
You asked me for a ride.
I got to do what I gotta do you know what I was thinking?
How crazy.
That's fucking crazy.
Joey.
I wish you could do your own.
Stand by me.
My fucking God.
This is who is this?
Why is this headset small?
When I got this picture,
which one?
The Filipino kit.
Now this guy of left that kids like a zillion and now his family owns a tow
truck company in northern New Jersey and New York City.
If you get told his family is the one that owns it,
I swear to God,
I believe.
Yeah.
This is fucking crazy shit,
I believe.
Yeah,
it's fucking crazy,
man.
Since you know,
1970 somebody sent me this yesterday while I was eating dinner and I almost had
a fucking heart attack goes out.
What I found looking through your books and that's what I was noticing.
I was smoking dope then I was no innocent.
Then I was smoking dope.
I was finger bang and people,
like I said,
they'll be innocent and finger back at me and my mom at the house.
Yeah,
yeah.
I was okay.
I wasn't going crazy then why I grew up in jersey,
the PA out or is the geared more towards boxing?
When I was in New York City,
it was a,
it was a place that they had like a boxing,
they had a pool table,
they had a,
you know sodas and shit like that.
Activities you might like ceramics and shit depending on your age and Jersey.
It was more Mr Gameo.
Mr Gameo was a Cuban dude and he ran the boxing program and I just knew it was
two sons,
Julio and season.
They got me a job at putting on the field.
Then they were like,
listen,
when you get the job,
you got to rub putting them fuels right by sea caucus off of route three.
It's dirty truck.
People go in that and job.
I lasted about three weeks before they fired me,
but I left after three weeks.
The guy at night was a half a momo.
His name was Freddy,
even though it's telling you this.
So we robbed the one that we go listen,
we're just gonna have them be Freddy up.
We were like sophomores in high school.
We'll put mask on me and deedee can Tara and when he comes out,
because in Jersey you pay the gas guy,
you don't go into a store,
you know they pump your gas.
So if you robbed the Guy,
you basically robbed the joint.
Do you follow me?
Only Oregon and New Jersey is where the people pumped your gas.
Everybody else,
you walk in with a card.
So we were kids.
We were like,
let's rob a fucked up Freddy.
You know when I worked there,
I got to know Freddy Freddy's wife looked like honey boo boos mother.
But he was a little guy.
But he brought,
his wife was like 400 pounds and the only way she would let him fuck him as if
he brought blow home and he was a skinny,
tiny guy like Eddie Bravo.
She was like three 90 and she would actually put the Bikini and they,
they were such white trash.
They lived in a studio apartment and they would rent the Jacuzzi and putting in
the living room.
These people were fucking,
they lived on the third floor.
Oh my God.
And it was the worst building in the neighborhood.
And they had black Marlowe.
She was the only black girl in the neighborhood,
black bottle.
I don't know what black Marlowe is today,
but she's the Real Martin Luther King.
She was the only black girl in a white neighborhood and Jersey girl look
torture.
She got tortured.
I always loved black.
Marlo.
Marlo was tight with me,
her mother was white.
Something had happened.
I for houses fucked up.
That building was fucked up.
So I used to go with it,
selling bloat.
I remember Freddy opened up the door and they would like a roll bar and his his
fat wife and living with heels with a bikini on and he's like,
thank you for bringing it to me.
Like he really was like,
when you brought him to blow,
he was fucking thankful that you fucking like,
thank you man.
I'm like,
what's it tonight?
Like she would not give me my hand job if he didn't have blow.
So finally,
so finally one day me and Deedee can tell,
we decided,
let's go down and rob this motherfucker on a Saturday night.
Let's wait until about midnight when he's got a grand on them because you,
you own dropped,
you get 2000 so it'd be 2000 you make a drop in the floor safe and you can't get
back in there.
So me and Dee Dee went behind the building by sea cock and it was right next to
this hot dog place that be nappies.
The rumor was with that's what the ice man killed somebody and put them in a
tank by snapping nappies.
Not,
this is a real fucking area jersey.
This is across the street was one of the biggest strip clubs and the east coast
not when I was there.
Robin,
Freddy a couple of years after that,
like the army base,
so you remember if you lived in New York,
they called this to the air force base some basis,
some shit.
But when we were kids we went there like at 12 and we took Freddy down.
Doug,
we just tagged with a master like kicking him,
like they kicked the whatever his name is and that Deniro movie in the bar and
we took his little person.
We ran away and he guessed it like it took him a week.
He's like,
you guys robbed me last night cause we had masks on and shit.
We're like,
Freddy wasn't us.
He's like,
yes it was.
I heard your voices.
Then he came back to us.
He's like,
listen,
I'll let your Robbie once a month,
but you got to split the money with me second by an eight ball to fuck my wife.
Once a month we'd go down and get a steady Freddy and beaten and we kicked the
fuck out of it.
Just I'm pressing let you do it.
He wanted to do with the cops,
you know that's the only way to cops and we did it like eight times.
Give black eyes bloody noses and some of the stomach couple of times.
That was it.
We need them.
Neon belly,
I don't even know what it was.
No video back then either she had to leave marks on him.
Yeah,
you have like kick him a few times.
I couldn't do it.
I had too much of a harsh,
I always had a higher,
like I had to bring like one of my crazy friends
that was having like a bad week.
There's a kid in Miami today that every time,
every time I place south Florida,
he shows up with his girlfriend and he gets fucked up and he tells a story.
When I knocked on his door with a diagram on how we were going to rob Freddy and
he goes,
that's when I knew that you were fucking for real.
He goes,
I was eating dinner with my family.
You can knock on the door and had a sketch like the deal,
how you are going to kick them and run into the weeds and go right to the coke
dealer house.
Like I had it planned.
We had done it so many times,
but I had to keep getting different partners because I couldn't hit Freddie.
All I could do was tackle them.
I was good at tackling them and then we want to go down and have my friend kick
him a few times.
It was fucking horrible.
But when you're 16 jail,
what the fuck though?
You've got to have a good time.
You know
you're not going to kick study Freddy.
You're going to kick Jesus Christ
brought,
we would rob them once every six weeks and finally it ended.
I didn't bring up the eight ball
when that I just did his eight boy.
He got pissed off at me and that was it.
Shame on people.
People are just silly when people take the time,
knowledge that shit or we are in,
no I don't.
Well it's you know,
but also no,
shut up.
Right.
But it's also people on both ends.
Like you choosing to get upset about some really ridiculous should read the
tweet and you go to that person's page and you go,
I get it.
Once I read somebody tweet and I go to their main page,
I get to put,
I can add it right in.
One Minute I go,
I get it.
I get where he was coming from.
I understand why he said that.
He's a musician.
He's daddy's a politician.
He sells this.
He likes,
like today somebody hit me and I ran.
He was a poor riser fan.
I get it.
You're a fucking book.
You know what I'm saying?
I've never met a Paul Riser Fan,
so if you're a poor riser fan,
shoot yourself in the fucking mouth right now.
Once somebody said,
if I go to some of these pains and I see like music and I know the music sucks,
that's where it ends because of his choice of music sucks.
That's what if I don't see fucking one of my three on there,
like I'm going to people's that.
There's two things I judge people.
I don't judge people by money and not legit people.
That music collection,
by looking at your music collection,
you don't have sabbath paranoid if you don't have the staples Zeplin too.
Those are the staples.
If you don't have a Zeppelin to,
why are we here?
Why not smoking dope with you?
Why are you wasting my fucking time?
I'm over here.
You got like best Judy Granddad.
You know what I'm saying?
That's and number two,
when you open up some of these refrigerator,
there's certain,
yeah,
it's true.
You opened that tells me everything.
If you're a fucking mood,
if you're a month,
if I see like low and beer,
your fucking money.
I ain't never coming in.
And I knew certain people that um,
they have music laying around just because it's cool,
but I'm tons of them.
That's why the generation of people that want to say,
and I know this and I don't hate you cause I'm kind of the same way,
that they don't want to like Floyd.
They prefer to listen to,
oh that's so commercialized and some more receipt,
you know,
they make you feel bad.
The worst being that Tom Waits era.
Those mother fuckers are ones I want to punch him right in the fucking face
because they're the ones you're having a good time listening to something.
You're Bob and they want to like really impressed like some fucking dumped chick
with freckles or something.
Everybody's fucked already.
You know what I'm saying?
Everybody fucked all you need.
Just Tequila and the grammar blown.
She'll be sucking your dick and a fucking bathroom.
What do you want to be cool.
And the Tom waits heavy.
When's a time wait
fucking shot yourself?
Yeah,
that's good singing.
You want that?
You're a fucking idiot.
But the only reason that people would put that shit on is to try to overpower
you with that fucking star wars.
What do you call that?
The fucking thing with the mind jars.
The my jam.
My tray.
That's it.
Oh,
he's so,
oh my God.
He likes Tom.
Wait,
listen to that.
They're trying to let me sit you down with a gun next to yad you,
Tom.
That's good.
Fucking second.
That's the Beatles.
Y'All fucking shoot.
You fucking put a gun to your fucking at.
All right.
Telling me that's good music.
You're fucking 20 years old.
Knock it off.
Like when somebody says,
I like the Dave Matthews band.
I will pistol whipped.
You
have satellite satellite.
I'm the way up here.
She would this to me.
They would do an exodus by bucking Bob Marley.
I almost cracked the fucking car.
A white dude with no shoes on and a black new planner.
If fucking it's too.
It's too made up.
Uncle Joey stop it.
I think he's got some good songs.
Dave has got a few good.
So please,
you've got me emotional.
Thank God I got together.
Fuck this shit.
I was too quiet over there.
I hate all that shit.
Just listen.
You don't make it.
Just move over.
I can't stay up fucking time.
And the people you like Tom Waits look at them and go to their page and it'll
tell you the whole thing like that.
That something ain't right.
That vegans something there,
you know,
stop the pill.
Could pilgrims,
they care for something that you're like,
really,
you know New Jersey,
they've been dumping shit since the seventies sixties bro.
That,
that,
that's never going to be,
that's what's,
what's a,
what's that word?
RECO recognizable.
Reconcilable.
No.
The other word,
when you can't reverse it,
that's soil and New Jersey's gone.
[inaudible]
that soil in New Jersey.
I remember when that,
when they built the metal lands,
I remember how many animals all of a sudden I had in my living room because they
tore all that down,
that wildlife and next,
you know,
I was seeing,
I remember one night seen a possum the size of a small people fucking treat
fucking tree.
You saw me,
he walked like a fucking ate those things when,
when you call the police in Jersey,
I've got a possum here.
They shoot the fucking thing.
You shoot the fucking thing.
No shoot snakes in the naughty.
They shoot the fucking possible cause they play dead.
And then when the cops leave they fucking get up and they brushed me.
You could run over a fucking car with him.
I was running on mobile bicycles and throw names out of,
they brush themselves off
behavioral trait.
They Dave fucking some that's where playing possum.
Oh,
I seen a fucking possum that looked at me one night at like four in the morning.
I looked at him,
I was like,
what the fuck?
And he jumped on a treatment
and I was like,
this is fucking mind boggling Joey.
Oh,
it's ringing.
Check this out.
I think it's gonna work.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if he's going to answer.
You're on the radio,
I'm telling you right.
No,
the fucking doors over there.
We love you too.
Man.
Came in and just dropped a bomb.
Right?
He's the greatest fucking man.
When he shows all the fucking Michael Irvin and those guys in front of clubs and
he goes to Miami Dolphins use to ask the college guys to get them into the club.
That's how,
that's how I watched the trailer to the you.
What the fuck?
I was like,
sure.
It was a bunch of black gangsters or white coach go out and be black gangs.
There's a white guy goes a black,
I want you to bring it back.
I want high fives.
I want fucking change.
I want you to talk.
Fuck not celebrate and I want everything.
I want you to fucking humiliate these mother fuckers.
And then the guy from two live crew came out with his hose.
He had a fucking VIP bags and they will come out this week.
It my Dick.
I'm hard.
And those bitches knew what time it was.
And that's all.
Listen,
there's two things that drive black people to different levels.
That's when they hear two live crew.
When they go to red lobster,
black people lose their minds at red lobster.
Fuck Popeye's.
On Thursday you take,
you go to Sacramento Red lobster on Friday at about four 30 when they blow the
whistle,
blow the whistle.
It wasn't fun.
I had,
he broke my bull.
[inaudible] was one of them.
Let me just tell you the mark Babbitt story.
Mark Babbitt went to Freddy Soto and I'm looking for free tracks.
So Freddy came up to me at the comedy store and he goes,
hey man,
mark Babbitt stuff.
A free tress.
Send them a tape.
I refuse to send the tape,
especially if I'm at the motherfucking copy store.
Okay.
I'm not saying you know,
fucking tape.
Why is that?
I got busy shorts,
comedy store.
You want to tape you take a ride up here.
You want,
I'll send you a copy of the 10 45 spots I get.
I ain't sending you no tape.
I just,
I'd never said don't be a tape.
I refused.
Especially people from La that were calling me up again.
We're putting together a TV show.
We need to take a loving 50th comedy stuff.
No beer.
Yeah,
I don't fucking sending tapes.
Mark Babbitt.
I sent him a blank tape.
I sent that jerk off finally because the manager I had,
Ken Phillips,
he kept calling me saying that Guy Houston keeps calling you.
He wants you to send them a blank tape.
I fucking didn't send them a tape for a year.
Finally,
when dad went to fucking,
Ralph's bought a tape but an envelope and said,
put Joey d stand there was done and the tape,
you know that motherfucker call me a week later and say love my tape and he
hired me as a
the open for Bobby slate.
So fuck all you mother fuckers.
That whole tape thing
or booth.
When you go to a comedy club and you go to his office to get paid,
he's got a TV and he's got a thousand tapes.
I haven't with dust on them.
He don't watch those fucking things.
That's his fucking power booth.
Okay,
Sam,
be a tape.
I came.
Do you?
You go someplace and they sign you up and you come back to this.
I listen.
You get as many minutes as people you bring,
you're earning your keep.
That's one thing I rather know where I stand and get fucked with.
That's the leg I'm talking about.
Really?
You need a tape of me.
You just saw him at the store.
What the fuck do you lead?
If I'm good enough for Mitzi shore.
Why do you want to take,
who the fuck are you and your fucking Shit town don't want to take from me.
I'm not the fucking major league.
I'm fucking comedy.
The comedy store.
You call me.
You want to tape go fuck yourself.
I'm not sending you a fucking day.
It's against my fucking,
well,
it's like these people now with movies and TV,
Joey,
they they want you to do with Costar,
but they want you to send the real,
don't don't send Shit Joey,
but they know it's a Costar.
They could offer it to me and if they don't that fine,
I'll do my podcasts and I'll live another week.
That's the mind and eventually it will go.
This motherfucker isn't gonna.
We might as well give it to them.
I'm not doing it for that.
You want me to fucking be a guest star recurring?
You want to give me a series regular?
I'll give you a fucking tape and I'll fucking to come down and talk to you.
But for Costar,
we've been doing this.
Look at the IMD.
Be What?
Fucking tape you decide.
Let me see your fucking tape.
Hey,
you said you know,
fucking tape.
Even then I had my fucking pride.
Even then,
I wouldn't send the fucking paper.
I refused.
I finally send them a blank tape.
He gave me that anti never have respect for none of them again,
because I found that it was a power play.
It was like,
you're on my court.
Uh,
you know,
you want to give me some respect but respect.
What do you do?
You're a pimp.
You take 20% of what people come to the fucking door.
What the fuck are you?
One of?
You don't,
you can't even play the fucking Ukulele.
The fuck are you doing?
You can't put a fucking Ukulele.
What the fuck have you done?
That's my,
that's where I'm coming from.
I didn't want them to sub club owners are bad,
but they did great jobs.
It was the shit.
They bold that in fucking like,
I don't like sexual stuff on television early.
He believed that girls making their own early.
You know,
like let's say I'm watching Diane Sawyer and have like a condom commercial.
I fucking lose my mind.
I of know Garcia bother you.
Oh,
it smells a little bit on really
camp on commercial.
I want to choke myself and my wife is in the room.
Or like your aunt's in the room or some older woman.
Since I was a kid,
they could a Kotex commercial.
I would sit down and look fucking straight ahead.
Dot.
I never get so embarrassed in my life.
I don't want them to ask me if I know and I don't want to fucking know.
The blood comes out of your snatch and what
and what you put up there.
That's got nothing to do with me.
I'm just a little straight that don't even bring it up.
You know,
there's some women that cute.
Yeah,
they think it's cute.
Like,
hold on,
I gotta go.
We gotta a Tampon.
Listen,
I don't want to know.
I don't want to love you bleed.
You just ruined everything for me.
And you know,
I don't want to know that.
That really bothered him.
I,
that bothers me.
The sight of blood.
No,
no,
no.
I hate the side of talking about that.
You're fucking pussies bleeding around me.
That's why I fucking hate when even when they haven't that purse.
I got sick to my fucking stomach.
I don't want to see a fucking tampon around.
I don't want to fucking see a Tampon at all or right when I'm watching TV and a
tampon commercial comes out.
Even when I'm by myself,
I feel creepy.
That's a weird and can't condom commercials.
That new commercial with the chicks head popping out on the fucking thing with
that you put on your finger to have you seen that fucking commercial to check
with the creepy finger to try.
You know?
This is great to relieve stress.
You know what,
man,
I don't want to know about that shit.
Play walked off.
Fuck is that?
Oh my God.
The Zombie.
Is that,
is that a Zombie to put that away?
That's broken.
That one's broken.
That is just,
that means that even get that one fixed.
So this day,
anything back in those sprays?
Anything.
Badging on television like 10 o'clock drives me up a fucking wall.
I've never had a period problem.
Oh,
automatic period.
Never had my own period.
Well,
I have my own period every now and then,
but I've never had a like a period problem,
like a problem with the girls period.
It doesn't bother me at all.
I told you the one I had to his day and it was fucked up because my mother had
just died and it was the first time a chick called me.
Like,
that was my first booty call ever.
I had dated this girl before.
She was a cheerleader at Franklin school.
I played hoops at Mckinley and we had messed around a little bit.
Not really Saks,
I don't remember Joe.
I think I sucked the titties.
I knew a brother,
you know what I'm saying?
Like we were like in grammar school,
high school and I had to suck to Teddy's or something after like a dance or
something.
And after my mother died,
like I was home for a week and this lady was taking care of me and I get this
call one night and it's this chicken.
She goes,
you know,
you want to get together?
Not,
I was feeling bad,
you know,
I didn't know.
She's told me a little lottery pussy,
like my little funeral pussy and if it got funeral pussy,
but it exists.
You know she owned her own person.
Yeah.
Like after somebody dies in your family since you're causing such a dick.
Really?
Yeah,
because they go bad like that.
Like a maybe like a,
like a women got hang out at comedy clubs and these iconic rupees.
Yeah.
Like they have sex with Pete after somebody dies.
I'm serious.
But I knew her.
She probably just called me out of the kindness of my heart that make me feel
well.
So I walked from 38th street to 46 grabbed his bitch and walked back to my house
on 38th street.
I'm all fucking horn up.
We started swapping,
so I think a pants off.
I pop her panties off and the Kotex pussy like a tongue and one of those fucking
haunted houses.
Right.
And I just sat there frozen.
Like I had never seen that before.
I had never smelled that before.
I had never been around anything like that.
My mother had just died.
That was traumatic enough.
This was just all over.
The fucking
woman is still alive today.
To this day.
I don't even look on Facebook cause I might kill her because
she fucked me up.
Joe Rogan fucks me up.
I told him to pull up pants on.
I remember walking home the whole time I wanted to,
I didn't know how to control myself and
told his dad think about that motherfucker various because she thought,
I don't know.
That's the first time I ever seen a woman with a period and the last I made a
fucking point.
That's so funny.
I don't care how old I am.
If I'm in a bar,
I got a bag of coke and somewhere along the light that chicks that she got her
period.
That's where the conversation and it ends.
There's no more talking.
They used to have this freak.
They used to be this chick I used to mess around with and Hollywood and I knew
her cycle.
She would have a period from the 20th to the 25th I wouldn't answer her calls.
Those five nights dog like six or seven nights just to make sure everything
cleared.
Wow.
She never figured it out until this day.
She's never forgot that I wouldn't bring coke.
I'm gonna Waste Coke on the bloody pussy.
Fuck it.
I'll smell it by myself and Jack,
but it doesn't,
it's still feel good.
Let's see it just the way it looks.
You don't like the way it looks.
It's more I like it.
There's blood.
Is that bad enough for you?
That's fucking blood.
It's that bad enough for you right there that you're fucking blood.
No matter what you're doing.
You're fucking blood.
I know you like it.
I know red men gravy comes out.
I know you son of a bitch.
We never heard about like mental illness when I was a kid I heard about like
completely crazy people that were locked in an asylum.
But the idea of like your aunt taking pills because she's bipolar.
Like what are you talking to?
He taught her cause it was accepted and everyone did it.
He knows like,
Oh yeah,
we used to take Valium and what skill?
I think it's the opposite.
I think you just get used to people being fucking crazy.
You know?
You didn't feel like you had a medicate them?
You know,
I think people were way more crazy in the sixties and seventies I do.
Johnny Reid,
I tried to kill himself,
but he jumped off a building,
a land in the dumpster.
How bad was he?
Broken.
Fucked up.
He fucked up and he throws punches into Johnny Ray was a trip.
It was,
and he got a check from the government and he gave it to my bartenders around
the first.
That's what people thought.
But he lived like,
he banged his head.
I'm a dumpster fucking over the dog.
He lived and he gives his check from the government on the first to the
bartender and he tore the bartender to,
that check was done and they'd throw him out for the first and they will last a
little about the 18th and 19th when I was a kid,
I used to tour,
met Johnny Ray.
He goes through on the east coast.
You'd locked the bathroom from the,
yeah,
collected.
Lucky.
So you liked the baptists of the outside of the east coast.
When you leave a bar at night,
when they close up right.
They locked the bathroom and then they put like a,
a lock or if you break in,
they can't,
he would go in the bathroom.
Johnny read like 11 o'clock in the morning,
the P and we locked him in there.
We leave them in there until like six o'clock at night.
We come back to have a drink.
We'd open the bathroom and he'd come out like nothing.
I swear to God,
like nothing happened.
He was hilarious.
One day I put my Dick on a chair next to him.
He was sitting at a Boston,
my friends like,
put your Dick,
see what happens.
And he's like,
wow.
And he just got up though Johnny relived.
It's like maybe 12 years ago,
we used to give him bumps a coke and get them riled up at the bar and they just
leave.
Fuck you motherfuckers.
I'll fight Ali.
Is that he just fucking leave for that reason anyway.
Did you,
uh,
Jennifer have a great data to kill herself?
No.
They should've
put that fucking helmet committee.
Your fucking Dick.
And yet he should kill yourself.
Kill yourself the first time.
And when you get to your destination.
I think when I needed the drugs,
he was one of my whole body was in pain and it's not pain that you feel.
It's just this pain and it was awesome.
You did it for so long.
Your body became accustomed to using beginning.
But in the beginning,
why is the main reason we get down?
Why is the main reason that guy like you and lose you have pain in your life
growing up?
We all do.
What made you different than not doing it?
You know,
when you,
uh,
when you first get involved in that,
your body hurts.
Man,
I can't imagine.
You know,
when I was 17,
I go home at the end of the night when I was in school,
I had to go to school at seven 30.
It's not going high school.
Junior.
I had to go to school and I would come home and sit in the corner in the dark
with headphones on with an eight track black sabbath and I just do coke two or
three in the morning.
He says,
Christ,
no drinking just to cope.
What possesses you do that,
Joe Rogan?
I Dunno.
What's it,
cause that was a junkie.
No,
I was,
you know what?
I was in so much pain what it,
but pain covers this huge thing when you're doing drugs.
Pain could be uh,
you know,
fucking confusion.
Pain shows up as confusion.
Confusion shows up as pain is what I'm saying to you.
Confused.
So I was 16.
It could be emotional pain,
it could be a launch,
doesn't have to be physical.
Whole body's in pain and you're doing it.
You know,
I talked to the head that totally could kid I kidnapped,
you know,
I call them a lot now.
Wow.
Guilty.
I'm really fucking guilty of that because I saw something when I get knocked him
that it's not Joe Diaz.
I saw him suffering.
I saw him at one moment on the floor,
handcuffed and I would never want that to me.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I always dreaded that happens to a friend of mine for what I did.
And I always felt bad.
I had call on the podcast and I apologized to him and I always call him up and I
called him the other day and we were talking and they told me,
you know,
every time I talked to him,
he tells me more about his life,
Bro.
You know what happened since I kidnapped him.
I bumped into him in [inaudible] 94.
I kidnapped them and 87,
I bumped into him in [inaudible] 94 and I bought coke from him.
He was all fucked up at,
at uh,
at Pearl Street down in boulder.
And then he never remembered.
I think he blacked out.
That's how bad a shape he was.
And I asked him,
but last but not this time,
but the time before I asked him,
do you me buying blow from you?
He goes,
I remember seeing it.
I remember hating you the next day to leave.
I didn't knock you the fuck out because I caught him off guard.
He was at a bar all fucked up.
I got saw me some blowers.
I look Hosea,
the guy who kidnap me,
the guy who could that mean,
but I called him blow after him after you kidnapped him and before you apologize
for kidnap.
And actually the way that you guys all met,
I saw him at a bomb pro street.
Did you even say,
I'm sorry I kidnapped you.
Not that night.
I just gave him a hug and asked him if he knew where it gets him blow his shit.
Gave me a hug and I always go to the bottom of one.
I apologize.
That felt really bad.
And I talked to him,
he had Danny and he started telling me he's 50 he moves with his mother.
He had a heart attack.
You know,
I could tell when I talked to him and in his pictures on Facebook that he had a
stroke,
you know,
that was often the blow bro.
Sometimes when he calls me and I could tell he's drinking,
you know,
and sometimes I feel real guilty,
did I do this?
But then you know,
I'm the type of guy,
I don't play that shit.
You know,
I don't play that shit at all.
He was fucked up when I get in that though,
a couple of weeks before,
you know,
how are we got how this whole thing started was because he got a Dui fucked up
some cars,
went to bold the hospital.
I'm on North Hospital,
boulder general,
and while he was in there,
you know,
boulder,
he was hurt.
They left them in a room by himself and he stole a bottle,
liquid coke cans and jumped out the window.
Okay.
And they call them and I will lay down the other side of the bulb.
You steal a bottle of liquid cocaine from the hospital.
You already got prom.
Oh my God.
Kidnapping Him.
You know?
And we laugh and we giggle.
Me Kidnapping Him.
It makes me feel blank.
Maybe I contribute to that,
but I didn't.
He had his own doom.
Why didn't I get fucked up?
You know?
I mean,
I got fucked up,
but in different ways,
I paid in different ways because the guilt in me doing that to a man fucking
destroyed me.
You know?
I like to fuck around.
I could do something bad if somebody harms me.
But even with Jujitsu,
I just can't put my form and some of these face,
man,
I hate when I have to lay on somebody.
Like I'll check on him and got you.
Okay Bro.
You know I love you right now.
I would look at me.
Do I know?
You know,
it's funny.
So for me,
seeing him in that corner,
I always had that guilt that I tied him up.
[inaudible]
okay.